[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ:
Last lecture, we
introduced the notion of
the limit of a function
as x goes to c, which
we write limit x arrow
c, f of x equals L.
What does this mean?
This means for all
epsilon positive,
there exists a delta positive
such that for all x in S
satisfying 0 is less than x
minus c is less than delta,
we have that f of x minus
L is less than epsilon.
And we proved the following
theorem last time,
that if we have a set,
a cluster point of S--
so this is where we
look at limits and f
as a function from S to
R-- then the limit as x
goes to c of f of x equals L if
and only if for every sequence
x sub n converging to c, we
have f of x n, the new sequence,
converges to L. So this
theorem here connects limits
of functions to what
we did previously,
limits of sequences.
Now, using this
theorem, we'll get
analogs of theorems we
proved for sequences, but now
for limits.
First, let me show a few simple
applications of this theorem.
So for example, we could
prove the following--
that for all c in R, the limit
as x goes to c of x squared
equals c squared.
So we could have done this
using just the definition,
but now with this
theorem, we can
prove it a little bit
quicker and easier,
because we essentially
did all the hard work when
we proved that the product
of two convergent sequences
is convergent, which
is what we'll use here.
So we're going to prove
this theorem using
the previous theorem.
So let x n--
so for this theorem,
since it's not stated,
you should take the function
to be f of x equals x squared.
And then the set that is
defined on S is equal to R
So let x n be a sequence such
that x n converges to c as n
goes to infinity.
We now want to
show that f of x n
converges to f of c, where
f of x equals x squared.
But this follows from
what we proved for limits.
So we proved the product
of two convergent sequences
is convergent.
By earlier theorem
about the product
of convergent sequences, we
get that x n squared converges
to c squared, which implies--
so we've now verified for
every sequence converging
to c, f of x n,
meaning x n squared,
converges to c squared.
And therefore by the
previous theorem,
we've proven the claim.
So now let's use this term to
study a couple of more limits.
And we use this
theorem, in fact,
to show that a certain
limit does not exist.
So the limit as x goes
to 0 of sine 1 over x--
this limit does not exist.
So remember for a limit,
I look at all those points
x that are close to
c, but not equal to c.
So this function, which
I'm taking the limit
as x goes to 0 of,
doesn't need to be
defined at x equals 0 in
order to consider the limit.
And if you like,
the function sine
of 1 over x is defined on
S equals R take away 0.
So this limit does not
exist, but the limit
as x goes to 0 of x times
sine of 1 over x does
exist and equals 0.
Now I want you to
note something--
you can't just stick in x equals
0 here to evaluate the limit.
Because then you'll be taking
sine of 1 over 0 times 0.
You can't divide by 0, so
can't just say this limit
equals 0 because I
stick in x equals 0.
In fact, we saw in
the previous lecture
that the limit need not
equal the function evaluated
at that point.
So just to recall the
example from last time,
when I had f of x equals 1 if
x equals 0 and 2 if x does not
equal to 0, then we
showed that limit
as x goes to 0 of f of
x equals 2, which note,
does not equal f of 0.
When we discuss
continuity, that's
what connects the limit
to the function evaluated
at that point.
I just want to make
that little comment.
To prove this theorem,
we're going to use, again,
the previous theorem.
Maybe I should-- no, I'm
not going to label it.
You'll know when
I point up to it
that I'm referring to that
theorem that I stated up there.
So in fact, let's
prove the second limit
exists and equals 0 first.
So suppose x n is a
sequence converging to 0.
We now want to show that
x sub n times sine of 1
over x sub n converges to 0.
And then the previous
theorem up there
will imply that
the limit as x goes
to 0 of x times sine
of 1 over x equals 0.
Now, if I look at the absolute
value of x sub n times
sine of 1 over x sub n, this
is equal to the absolute value
of x sub n times the
absolute value of sine of 1
over x sub n.
And no matter what
you stick into sine,
sine is always bounded
between 1 and minus 1.
So the absolute value
is always bounded by 1.
So just to summarize,
we've shown that--
and now we apply
the squeeze theorem.
So that goes to 0.
It's just the constant
sequence equal to 0.
Since x sub n is
converging to 0--
remember we're assuming that--
this converges to 0.
And therefore, what gets
trapped in between goes to 0.
So by squeeze theorem,
x sub n times sine of 1
over x sub n converges to 0.
And that proves the second claim
So now we'll prove 1.
And in the previous lecture,
I did negate this definition.
So let's actually
negate this theorem,
if you like, or use the
negation of each side of this if
and only if to state
an equivalent theorem.
So two statements
are equivalent,
which is in that theorem, if
and only if their negations
are also equivalent.
So by the theorem, we also
have the following fact--
limit x goes to c of f
of x is not equal L if
and only if there exist--
so negating the right-hand side
of that if and only if-- there
exists a sequence x
n converging to c--
so this sequence will--
consisting of elements
of S take away
c, such that x n
converges to c, but we
don't have f of x n converging
to L. And when I write this,
you should read this as either
this limit exists and does not
equal L or this
limit does not exist.
So I'll even write that out--
and either limit does
not exist or does not
equal L. So again,
that's an equivalent
way of stating the
theorem up there
is in terms of the negation.
Two statements are equivalent,
which is right there, if
and only if their
negations are equivalent.
So now, we're going to prove
that the limit as x goes
to 0 of sine of
1 over x does not
exist by showing that there
exists a sequence converging
to 0 such that when I
plug that in to sine,
the limit of that
sequence does not exist.
So to show there exists
a sequence converging
to 0 such that limit as n
goes to infinity of sine of 1
over x sub n does not exist.
Now, sine oscillates
between 1 and minus 1
depending on a certain
multiple of pi over 2.
So here's the
intuition behind it,
behind the sequence
I'm about to give you--
note that sine of x equals
1 if x equals pi over 2,
5 pi over 2, 9 pi over 2,
and so on, minus 1 if x
equals 3 pi over 2, 7 pi over
2, 11 pi over 2, and so on.
So I can stick in things
that are getting bigger
to sine and get 1 or minus 1.
And in fact, let me
change this to y,
since we're using x to
be essentially 1 over y.
So if I stick in pi over 2, 5 pi
over 2, 9 pi over 2, and so on,
I get sine equals 1.
If it's 3 pi over 2, 7
pi over 2, 11 pi over 2,
and I stick that into
sine, I get minus 1.
But that means if I stick
1 over these numbers
into sine of 1 over
x, I get 1 or minus 1.
And so then that
sequence that I get
will be 1 or minus
1 alternating.
And we know that sequence
does not converge.
So that's the idea.
So let me write that down.
Let x sub n be 1 over
these numbers, essentially,
so 2n minus 1, pi
over 2, minus 1,
because we're going to
stick this into sine of 1
over x, which is 2 over
2n minus 1 over pi.
Now, note for all n, x sub
n is less than or equal to--
I can write this as 2
over n plus n minus 1 pi.
And since n is bigger
than or equal to 1,
this is always bigger
than or equal to 0.
So this is less than or
equal to 2 over n pi.
And this goes to 0.
So that shows by
the squeeze theorem
that this sequence I've
defined here converges to 0.
But what happens when
I plug this sequence
into sine of 1 over x?
This is now equal to sine
of 2n minus 1 pi over 2.
And this is therefore
equal to 1 minus 1,
1, minus 1, 1, minus 1.
And this sequence, which
is just equal to minus 1
to the n plus 1--
I don't know why I capitalized
that-- does not converge.
So we found a sequence
converging to 0 such
that when I stick it
into the function,
that new sequence
does not converge.
So we've proven that this
limit does not exist.
So I alluded to this fact
that this theorem will give us
theorems that are
similar to what
we proved for sequences, except
now for limits of functions.
So let me just state the
simplest theorem you can get.
So let S be a subset of
R, c a cluster point of S,
and suppose I have two
functions f going from S to R
and g going from S to R.
If these two limits
exist, and one function
is smaller than
the other, then--
so we had an analogous
statement for sequences,
which was if I have two
sequences converging
and one is less than
or equal to the other,
then one limit is less
than or equal to the other.
And it's an analogous conclusion
for limits of functions.
So again, the analogous
statement for sequences
was we have two
sequences, one less than
or equal to the other, which
then the limit of the smaller
sequence is less than or equal
to the limit of the bigger
sequence.
So let's give the proof.
And we'll use this theorem
connecting limits of functions
to limits of sequences.
And then we'll use the
corresponding statement
which we do have for
sequences, which I just
stated a couple of times.
So let L1 be the
limit as x goes to c
of f of x, and L2 the limit
as x goes to c of g of x.
And what we want to show is that
L1 is less than or equal to L2.
Let x n be the sequence,
and S takeaway c such
that x n converges to c.
Such a sequence exists because
c is a cluster point of s.
And you proved in the assignment
that if I have a cluster
point of S, then there exists
a sequence in S takeaway c
that converges to c.
Now, since-- say it this
way-- by the previous theorem,
this limit equals L1, this
limit equals L2 if and only
if for every sequence converging
to c, f of x n converges to L1,
g of x n converges to L2.
By the previous theorem,
we then conclude
that L1 is equal to the
limit as n goes to infinity--
actually getting ahead
of myself a little bit.
So let's pause right
there and reset.
So now we have the
sequence converging to c.
Then by the assumption
here for all n, f of x n
is less than or
equal to g of x n.
And since f of x
n converges to L1,
and g of x n converges
to L2, we get by, again,
this theorem about sequences,
which says if I have two
sequences, f of x sub n-- this
is one sequence is less than
or equal to another
sequence, g of x n--
and they both converge,
then the limits
satisfy the same
inequality, which
is what we wanted to prove.
So like I said,
this theorem here
follows from the analogous--
in fact, I should have
written this out or in fact,
I will write it out now.
So the analogous statement for
sequences was if for all n,
a n is less than or
equal to b n, then limit
as n goes to infinity, assuming
both limits exist, satisfy
the same inequality.
So this is an analogous
theorem to this theorem,
which we had for sequences.
And we used this theorem
from sequences to prove it.
Now, following that
same philosophy,
you can prove
analogous statements
for functions,
limits of functions,
as you did from sequences.
You get these for free.
And instead of stating
all of the theorems we
did for sequences except
now for limits of functions,
I'm just going to quickly
say you get the same thing.
So by using the
previous theorem, which
connects convergence
of functions
to convergence of sequences, we
have analogous theorems for--
and let me state it this way--
for limits of functions now.
And for example, you
have the squeeze theorem,
namely if I have--
so just talking this out--
if I have three functions,
say f is less than or
equal to g is less than
or equal to h, and f of x
and this converges to L,
h of x converges to L,
then g of x converges to L.
That's what I mean by
analogous statement.
You also have theorems
about algebraic operations
and limits, meaning that if
I have two functions that
have limits as x goes
to c, then f plus g will
have a limit as x goes to c.
And the limit of the sum
is the sum of the limits.
Same thing with the product, and
same thing with the quotient,
assuming the limit on
the bottom is nonzero.
And then similarly,
we also have a theorem
about the absolute value
and limits, namely if f of x
converges to L as x goes to c,
then the absolute value of f
of x converges to the absolute
value of L as x goes to c.
So you have all of these
analogous statements,
or theorems that are analogous
to the statements from what
we did for sequences, but
now for limits of functions
as x goes to c.
And I'm not going
to state them all.
You can see this
in the textbook.
Maybe the proof of some of
them I'll give as exercises.
Now let's separate
the notion of a limit
of a function from that of a
sequence just a little bit.
So unlike when we talk
about limits of sequences,
here we're letting a point
x converge or get close
to a point c, but
there's two ways
it can get close to c
on the real number line.
It can converge
to c from the left
or it can converge
to c from the right.
And this leads to the notion
of left and right limits
of a function.
So start the definition here
and we'll go to the next board--
so let S be a subset
of R, and suppose c
is a cluster point
of minus infinity,
0 intersect of c intersect S.
So what I'm defining
now is the notion
of a function
converging to something
as x goes to c from the left.
That's why I'm looking at only
S intersect minus infinity to c.
So I'm only looking
to the left of c.
We say f of x converges to L as
x converges to c from the left
by putting a minus sign up here
if a similar definition as that
of the limit, but
now we only look
at x getting close
to c from the left.
If for all epsilon
positive there
exists a delta positive
such that for all
x in S satisfying c minus delta
is less than x is less than c--
so it's close to c
but to the left of c--
we have that f of x minus
L is less than epsilon.
And in this case,
we write the limit
as x goes to c with the minus
sign up top, f of x equals L.
And then we have an
analogous definition
for converging to or taking
a limit of a function
as x goes to c from the right.
If c is a cluster
point of c infinity,
c comma infinity intersect S--
so I shouldn't say if--
[INAUDIBLE] is a cluster
point of, now just taking S
that's to the right of c, then
we say that f of x converges
to L as x converges to c plus,
meaning as x converges to c
from the right, if for all
epsilon positive there exists
a delta positive such that for
all x in S satisfying c is less
than x is less
than c plus delta--
so now it's close to c
but to the right of c--
we have that f of x minus
L is less than epsilon.
And similarly to the
notation up there,
we write limit as x goes to
c plus of f of x equals L.
Now, just like we proved
this theorem for limits,
you can state and prove
an analogous statement
for one-sided limits.
So such a statement
would be, for example,
limit as x goes to c
minus of f of x equals L
if and only if
for every sequence
x sub n satisfying x sub n is
less than c converging to c,
we have f of x n converges to L.
So these two just kind of limit
how f behaves near a
point c if we're just
looking to the left of c or to
the right of c, but not at c.
So let's, for example, look at--
I think this is usually referred
to as the heavy side function.
So f of x equals 0 for x
less than or equal to 0,
and 1 if x is bigger
than or equal to 0.
So the graph is like that.
And why do people care
about this function?
Well, in a certain sense,
if you take the derivative
of this function, you get
what's called the Dirac delta
function, although
that's not a function.
That's a distribution.
But that's why this
function has a name attached
to it because if you
take its derivative,
you get something
somewhat special.
Anyways, we're not
even at derivatives.
We're not even going to
talk about distributions
in this class.
So let's get back
to one-sided limits.
So if I look at this function
for x close to 0 from the left,
f is just 0.
So in fact, since I'm only
looking at x to the left of 0
in this limit, this is just
plugging in x less than 0,
so I get 0.
And that's just 0.
And if I look at this
function from the right,
to the right of 0,
then f of x is just 1.
It's just 1 identically.
And so I get--
and it's, again,
although I haven't
shown that one-sided limits of
constants equal to constant,
I think that should be
something you can easily
believe or write out yourself.
So for this function,
we see that it
does have two-sided limits,
except those limits don't
equal each other.
And they certainly don't equal--
so this one does equal f of 0,
but I could have made
f of 0 to be a 1/2,
and then this still
would have been 0,
and not equal to the function
evaluated at the point.
So again, I'm making this point
that for limits, just limits,
it does not matter what the
function is doing at the point.
Limit only cares
about how a function
behaves near a a point.
One-sided limits
augment that by saying
we're only going to care about
the function near the point
and to the left
for the left limit,
and to the right
for the right limit.
So I didn't say that, but
this we call the left limit,
this we call the
right limit, simply
because we're getting
close to c from the right
and from the left.
But what is the connection
between left and right limits?
We have the following--
let S be a subset of R, f
be a function from S to R,
and suppose that c
is a cluster point
of both sets minus
infinity to c intersect S.
And c infinity
intersect S. That way
I can talk about the left and
right limits of c or at c.
Then-- so first off,
if c is a cluster
point of any one
of these sets, it's
going to be a cluster
point of the set S.
So we can actually
look at the limit.
So then the limit
as x goes to c of f
of x exists and
equals L if and only
if the limit as x goes to
c from the left of f of x
equals the limit as x goes to c
from the right of f of x equals
L.
So this kind of looks
like the theorem
we proved about lim
sup and lim inf,
but they don't have
any connection.
If you want to make some
connection between the way
this theorem looks and the
statement of the theorem
for lim inf and lim sup, so this
is kind of saying that limit
of a function equals L if
we approach from the left
or right the function
f approaches L.
And for the lim sup lim inf
guy that we did for sequences,
you could take that as saying
that the limit of a sequence
equals L if and
only if following
the sequence from below,
that approaches L,
and following the sequence from
above, that also approaches L.
So there's kind
of two directions
there, just as there's
two directions here,
but not really.
So let's give a quick
proof of this theorem.
It's not difficult. It
follows almost immediately
from the definitions.
In fact, I'm going to
do only one direction.
So this direction should,
assuming this, and proving
this should be pretty clear.
If I have this, this means that
if I want to be close to L,
I just need to be close to c.
And therefore, it
doesn't matter if I'm
close to c from
the left or right.
I'll be close to L.
And going this
direction, this says
I just need to be close
to c from the left,
sufficiently close,
and I need to be
close to c from the
right, sufficiently close,
to be close to L.
So really, there's
not a lot of trickiness
in the proof.
It's just writing
these things out.
And so I'm just going to
write out one direction
and leave the other
direction to you.
So let's assume that
the left limit equals
the right limit
equals L. And now we
want to show that
the limit as x goes
to c of f of x equals L.
Now we want to show limit
as x goes to c of
f of x equals L.
So let's go back
to the definition.
Let epsilon be positive.
We want to be able to
find delta so that f of x
is within epsilon to L if
x is within delta to c.
And what's the point?
Here's c and here's L.
So this is the picture
that goes along with this.
Assuming these two
limits equal L,
I know that there
exists a delta 1 so
that if I'm in this
interval, then here's
L plus epsilon, L minus epsilon.
Then if I'm within delta
1 to c and to the left,
then f will be close
to L in that interval.
And then since the limit as x
goes to c from the right equals
L, there exists some delta 2
so that if I'm in this interval
then I'll be, again, close to L.
But this means that if I choose
the smaller of these two,
and I look at the
whole interval,
then f will be close to
L on the whole interval.
And that's it.
So let epsilon be positive.
Then limit as x goes to
c minus f of x equals
L, this implies there
exists delta 1 positive such
that if x minus c is
less than delta 1, then
I get that f of x c minus delta
1 is less than x is less delta
is less than c.
This implies that f of x
minus L is less than epsilon.
And similarly for
the right limit,
since limit as x goes to
c plus of f of x equals L,
this implies, by the definition,
there exists a delta 2 positive
such that if c is less than x
is less than c plus delta 2,
then I get f of x minus
L is less than epsilon.
Now choose delta to be the
minimum of delta 1 and delta 2.
And then we'll now show
that this delta works.
So now we're going to
show this delta works.
So if less than delta, then
this implies that either x
is in c minus delta--
so if we take something
close within delta
to c, and delta is the minimum
of these two distances, then--
for the sake of this
picture, let's say
delta 1 equals delta 2, so now
I'm looking at this interval--
then two cases.
Either x is in c
minus delta c, which
is a subset of c minus
delta 1 c since delta
is the minimum of those
two deltas, which implies
by the first inequality here
for delta 1 or x is in c, c
plus delta, which
is a subset of c, c
plus delta 2, which by
our choice of delta 2
gives us that.
Thus we've shown that if x
minus c is less than delta,
then f of x minus L
is less than epsilon.
That's the end of the proof.
So I've said this
over and over again--
limits of functions don't care
about what the function is
doing at the point.
It cares about what the function
is doing near the point.
Now we're going to discuss
the notion of continuity,
which connects the limit
of a function at a point
to the function.
So it connects how
a function behaves
near a point to the function
evaluated at the point.
And so you can even
write this down.
How a function behaves
near a point compared to--
so near, at.
And you'll see when I write
down the definition, basically,
what's staring
you in the face is
that the definition
of continuity
is that the limit as x goes
to c of f of x equals f of c.
So we had these examples
where the limit--
I think already erased it,
but where the limit exists
but does not equal f of c.
And here for continuity,
the notion of continuity
is that the limit as x goes
to c of f of x actually
equals the function
evaluated at that point.
So we have the
following definition.
Let S be a subset of R
and c an element of S.
We say f is continuous at c
if for all epsilon positive,
there exists a
delta positive such
that for all x and S satisfying
x minus c is less than delta--
so in particular, I
can now, for example,
x equals c will satisfy
this inequality.
I don't have the 0
is less than that.
So for all x and S which
are close to c within delta,
I have that f of x will be--
with an epsilon of f of c.
So in this case,
just a little f is
continuous at every point on its
domain that we're considering.
We just say f is continuous.
So for a function to be
continuous at a point nearby
x, x being near c,
should mean that f of x
should be near f of c.
And let's go through
some examples.
Remember, whenever
you get a definition,
you should look for examples
and then potentially negate it.
We'll negate this
definition in just a second
to show that a function
I wrote down a minute ago
is not continuous.
So the affine function f of
x equals a times x plus b--
so S is R, so x
is a real number--
is a continuous
function, meaning
it's continuous at
every real number c.
So let's prove this.
Let c be an element of R.
We want to show f
is continuous at c.
So we have to go
through the definition.
Let epsilon be positive.
Choose delta to be epsilon over
1 plus the absolute value of a.
And last time, in
the previous lecture,
I gave the intuition on why you
would choose this delta based
on the function and epsilon.
I did a computation here.
I'm just going to
choose delta this way,
and you'll see that it works.
So now we have to
show this delta works.
If x minus c is
less than delta, we
should be able to now show
that f of x minus f of c
is less than epsilon.
This is equal to a x
plus b minus a c plus b.
So this is equal to
a times x minus c,
which equals absolute value
of a times absolute value
of x minus c.
This is less than delta.
Absolute value of x minus c
is less than delta times a,
which equals the absolute
value of a over 1
plus the absolute value
of a times epsilon,
which is less than epsilon.
Because a number over
1 plus that number
is always less than 1.
Maybe you were
wondering, why didn't I
just choose delta to be epsilon
over the absolute value of a?
This is just a smidgen
of sophistication,
that what happens if
the absolute value of a
is equal to 0?
Then we would have divided by 0.
So adding a 1 there
takes care of that.
So this guy is
continuous at every c.
So this function is continuous.
How about a function that's
not continuous at a point?
Make sure this is
the next topic.
Here is a non-example.
The function f of x, which
equals 1 if x equals 0,
2 if x is not equal to 0.
That's the function.
f is not continuous at 0.
So to prove this, let's negate
the definition of continuity.
So the negation
of continuity is--
so f is not continuous at c if--
so the "for alls" become "there
exists," and "there exists"
become "for all."
So if there exists
some bad epsilon
so that for all delta
positive, there exist an x such
that x minus c is
less than delta,
and we do not have the second
inequality, f of x minus f of c
is bigger than or equal
to this bad epsilon.
Now for this guy, it's pretty
clear which x to choose.
So let's think this
out for a minute.
There should be some
bad epsilon 0 so
that if I take any
small interval around 0,
I can find a point
in this interval
so that f of x minus
f of c is going
to be bigger than or
equal to epsilon 0.
Now here, f of c is
f of 0, which is 1.
Now what would be the bad
epsilon so that f of 1
is greater than distance 1 or
greater than distance epsilon 0
to f of x for some
x in this interval?
Well, if I take any x in
this interval other than 0,
and stick it into f,
I'm going to get 2.
And that's greater than or
equal to distance 1 to f of 0.
So epsilon 0 I will
choose to be 1.
So now we want to prove that
f, this function here, is not
continuous at 0.
So I'll tell you what
the bad epsilon is.
Choose epsilon 0 equals 1.
So now we have to show this
bad epsilon 0 is indeed bad.
Let delta be positive.
We have to now find a
number in this interval
so that f of x minus f of 0
is bigger than or equal to 1.
And like I said a minute ago, if
you take any x in this interval
other than 0 and
stick it into f,
I get 2, which is
distance 1 to f of 0.
Let x to be delta over 2, say.
Then x minus 0 is
less than delta.
It's actually equal
to delta over 2.
And f of x minus f of 0--
this is equal to 2 minus 1,
which is bigger than or equal
to epsilon 0.
So this function
is not continuous.
And so next time-- and I'll
just leave this question here,
which we'll address
in the next lecture.
But it's a kind of
simple question.
So first off, if you
look at this function,
it shouldn't be too hard
to convince yourself,
so you're also told when you
were a child that a function is
continuous If you
can draw the graph
and not lift up the pencil,
which I better not see
on the exam if I ask
you about continuity.
But anyway, for the sake
of this conversation,
let's take that
as the intuition.
So you can convince yourself
that this function is
continuous over here, though.
If I'm getting close to--
let's say this is minus 1,
then the function is
getting close to 2.
And the value of the
function at minus 1 is 2.
So the function is getting close
to the value of the function
at minus 1.
And the same for if I'm
looking at c equals 1.
So you should be able
to convince yourself
that this function is
continuous at every point
other than at the origin 0.
So a natural question to ask is,
let f be a function, let's say,
defined on the whole
real number line.
Does there exist
a point in R such
that f is continuous
at this point c?
For this example over
here, we were able to--
any point other than 0, the
function's continuous there.
So natural question
is, let's say
I take an arbitrary function.
Does it have to have a
point where it's continuous?
And next time, we'll
see that answer is no.
We'll give an example
that's I think
due to Dirichlet because
it's named after him,
but naming doesn't necessarily
mean anything in math.
Green's theorem is named after
Green but he didn't prove it,
so maybe it was due
to somebody else.
And we'll use a similar
characterization of continuity
that's kind of analogous
to this first statement we
had for limits.
And we'll do that next time.